license and registration please
Isis registration is your license in
there can you pull it out for me please
it's off yeah you know how to fill one
of these in a long time ago I just like
your name and address that's all
do you have a license for that firearm
license registration get your answer
I've got my eye on you folks got the cab
get on the ground
your knees now back up put the gun down
you and me better take this a little
walk and you're under arrest
okay I have to take you downtown police
open up
Jerry's apartment how come you didn't
know of course that I was a cop I am the
mother after police don't you see I
interrogate him you write it down I just
want to hear your start the talk I think
I can save your life liar
just went south I'm gonna hang on it but
wake up the good news is you're spending
30 days without pay
she shut up rosewood Ajit's partner
Swede brothers and we need friends I
don't want a woman I will not allow you
to fail and then I I said playtime's
over
I hit with the priesthood guy thinking
did he fire six shots or only five
he's he tertiary everybody put your guns
back at the gun down baby's doctor cut
that I'm done not all cops - no but